all right looks like we're now live for
the next philosophy pop up this one for
May and since I have started well
actually much earlier in May the
existentialist philosophy and literature
online class that I'm teaching for
Milwaukee Institute of Art Design I
thought that might make a good topic to
talk about for the pop ups this month so
as I mentioned it's been a couple of
weeks it started I think on the 13th of
May runs for six weeks so one of the big
challenges with online classes in
general is figuring out how to pack in
as much information and materials for
the students as possible given the
usually shortened time frame you know
occasionally you get a full 15 week
semester course but a lot of times these
online courses are really quite
compressed so I had to think a lot about
what texts and what thinkers I was going
to do I started out with a rather
ambitious idea of having 11 texts and
thinkers and having the students get
three texts from each of the main
existentialist thinkers and one of them
would be required one would be what I'd
call supplementary and then one would be
optional and the idea would be that they
would have to read all of the required
texts which would be fairly short then
they would have to read half of the
supplemental texts and one or two of the
optional texts but then I looked at you
know how much time was required and and
how much you know they'd have to work
through and I said let's do two per you
know per author and let's cut out one of
the authors so we're looking at 10 which
is still really ambitious 10
existentialist thinkers I'll tell you
who they are in just a minute and then
you know we'll talk about which texts
we've actually got so I thought I'd have
a fairly short
and in some cases more or less
accessible text as the required text and
then a longer text or more difficult
text as the supplementary text and I
require them to engage at least two of
the supplemental text because they have
to write two course papers in the class
over those six weeks so who are the
figures that I decided well of course
you know the big three at the beginning
sir and Kierkegaard Fyodor Dostoevsky
and Friedrich Nietzsche I'd love to have
done love chef stuff but that was just
impossible so he went by the wayside we
jump right into Rainer Maria Rilke who
they're reading right now and Martin
Heidegger and then the next week we're
doing Franz Kafka and Gabrielle Marcel
with Marcel we enter into the French you
know existentialist phase and then the
last three figures are Albert Camus
jean-paul Sartre and Simone de Beauvoir
and I was gonna do France fun own I
really wanted to get into him but
there's too much stuff already to pack
in there so that that's why we we left
him out I think if I do a longer version
of the class chef stuff is definitely
coming back in we'll do some Buber you
know we'll do Lu Andre Salome and we'll
do fun and we'll do some other figures
as well but those are the figures who I
have and you know the text that I have
for them for Kierkegaard actually to
require text that crowd is on the crowd
is on truth it's very short fragment and
then the present age which is you know
really quite good for our current age
and then fear and trembling is the
supplemental text for Dostoevsky notes
from the underground part one just part
one as the required text and then that
the grand inquisitor chapter from
Brothers Karamazov not the entirety of
mother's Karamazov as the you know
supplemental text and then for Nietzsche
we did part one of course
or of the spoke zarathustra and then the
genealogy of morals I don't know if any
of the students have selected that as
the supplementary text that's kind of
challenging but you'll see for Rilke the
required text letters letters to a young
poet and then the supplemental text
which again I don't know if they're
actually going to take this up or not is
the notebooks of malte lore it's bryggen
which is only real novel he's got some
shorter narrative pieces as well then
Heidegger is kind of a tricky one so I
had them read what is metaphysics and
we'll see if they make anything of that
right I gave them a lot of resources to
help them out but you know it's
Heidegger right and then for the
supplemental text I was thinking about
doing the origin of the work of art you
know since they are art and design
students but I also have this material
handy about you know the role of emotion
or mood among right and its relation to
understanding thoroughness language from
being in time so I decided to go with
that as the supplementary text I don't
expect it yes the more I read that is
the supplementary text but we'll see
we'll see what happens and then we go on
to Kafka the metamorphosis kind of a
no-brainer there and the supplemental
text is the trial and then Gabrielle
Marcel on the ontological mystery and
it's companion piece the play a broken
world for Camus parts of the mythos if
assists not the entire thing and then
the stranger is the Supplemental text
for Sartre
I'm having them read existentialism is a
humanism is the required text
supplemental text is nausea and then
finally for adieu boudoir
we have bits not not the entirety
because it's a book this thick of the
second sex and then the Supplemental
text is a play that translates sometimes
as the useless mouths or who should die
there's a couple different translations
of it out there a very good piece for
illustrating eggs
dentist choice and some of these other
you know key topics that are coming up
so that's what I'm having them read and
I think I'll answer some questions and
address some comments before I go on to
talk about how I structured the class
all right so canal asks have a read Nick
land I answer this every time nope and
if somebody wants me to read Nick land
they can send me the book somebody sent
me a PDF I don't I don't read I don't do
PDFs I do books that you hold in your
hand
so somebody really really wants me to
like talk about Nick land they can they
can send me a copy
I'm Robert Brandon I've read Brandon I
haven't bought his new book the spirit
of trust I don't spend a lot of time
with secondary literature as I think
many of you know because I spend so much
time working on primary texts brandon is
sort of a person who's kind of like
Trant you know he straddles secondary
and primary literature he's somebody
worth reading in his own right and I did
go to his lecture here in Milwaukee
earlier in the spring he gave the
Aquinas lecture at Marquette Robert
writes Berjaya yeah I mean I'd like to
have him in there as well but you know
he's kind of a more marginal figure as
is Boober and and chest off and people
like that so for this introductory class
he wasn't going to make it in there
Fahad says was nature truly original
announcing the death of God or was at a
general mood among people of that time
neither Hegel talked about the death of
God it was it was not a radically new
concept the meaning that Nietzsche gives
to it is kind of new this notion that
you know whatever the highest value is
has devalued itself and and we have to
live out the consequences of that I
would say that's that's kind of an
original thought to him although not
totally you know there are other people
who are looking into the proverbial
abyss as well all right Robert Sims
concluding unscientific PostScript is a
great existential text for those what's
still wanting to read more Kierkegaard
so sickness onto death
so is philosophical fragments so is you
know we can go on and on and on with
that sort of stuff yeah they're all
throw great I mean ideally when you have
a class like this you hope that the
students are going to continue on you
don't know you know you only find out
afterwards and I think a lot of them you
know take a class hoping that they're
gonna get introduced to a few thinkers
who later on they'll continue studying I
can tell you that myself you know when I
was an undergraduate and I would read
Kierkegaard I liked the present age I I
couldn't really get into the other
things because they they just struck me
as like too connected with religion and
I wasn't into that at the time and it
was only later on that I was able to
develop a really like in graduate school
I was really able to develop a a better
appreciation of Kierkegaard so so I I
think that you know what I do what I try
to do is present them with a lot of
paths that lead off somewhere and I try
to do that with others thinkers as well
all right hungry American says for the
class I took on existentialism oops just
jumped a little bit
the professor assigned Hana rents the
human condition do you think she's
considered an existentialist by the
ideas in that book or by her other ideas
some people consider her an
existentialist this is actually a good
place to stop and say there is no
definition of existentialist there is no
consensus on exactly where the borders
lie you'll never anytime that you find
somebody claiming that they're full of
crap or they haven't read enough because
it's it's a rather amorphous category
you know every time that I talk about
existentialism and Camus I'll get
somebody who said he wasn't understand
Shoeless well yeah sure he did that he
said that but he also fits the traits of
all these existentialist authors and
writes about them is an influenced by
them he means something different when
he's saying I'm not an existentialist
and what we mean by that and so you know
you can say a similar thing with a rat
she she criticizes existentialism
certain existentialist authors and
tenancy
in different places you can also say
something similar about Hans yonas
another student at Heidegger right in
his Gnostic religion he's got a whole
discussion of Gnosticism the nexus
tential ISM so it really depends on how
you want to define existentialism if you
think about it as philosophy that's
concerned with the human condition that
focuses on certain existential
experiential life and death events like
birth death love work all those sorts of
stuff she's solidly in there if you
think of it as a reaction against
totalizing tendencies of philosophy I'd
say she's in there as well but she's not
as central to it as other figures are
and there's no reason why you can't
can't you know read her into it
I'd say D fact says oh yes please fun
own even if I hate him for ruining
Africa Soviet agent perhaps I don't know
that fun own ruined Africa as such
Africa is a big place a lot of different
moving parts a lot of different things
going on there and you know it's also
good to remember just how young he was
at the time that he was engaging in his
writing and his in his work but he is
somebody who's definitely worth worth
checking out and reading his
phenomenological analyses you know all
right Robert Sims question concerning
technology sublime short piece yeah
although it you know I I've already got
stuff in the class dealing with some of
those themes like the Marcel piece deals
with techniques and technics actually
I'm putting stuff on the board for that
after I get off of here because I need
to shoot video material on that letter
on humanism would have been a great pick
for a supplemental text to start yes and
no we're reading Heidegger first because
everything's got to be you know this
again six-week class right everything's
compressed everything's in modules
for complete beginners and heidegger's
coming before Sartre so it doesn't
really make much sense to read the
letter on humanism when they haven't yet
read existentialism as a humanism for
doing like a 15 week full class now we
can have a back and forth like we you
know we do the some Heidegger stuff
first and then we do Sartre and we
include you know as part of the response
that Heidegger's you know discussion of
sart's views in letter on humanism but
in a six week compressed summer class
there's just no way that's gonna going
to work Robert Sims why do people care
so much about Nick land well because I
think he's very trendy and he's doing
some things that at least you know as
far as you know I couldn't tell from way
on the outside or kind of interesting
and I think people like the acceleration
ISM notion which is kind of a wax knows
people could make whatever they like of
it I I do think it's kind of a smart
thing for him to be like keeping his
Paul his finger on the Chinese pulse to
see what's going on there because when
it comes to like thinking about where
are where the human race is headed
Chinese culture civilization is going to
become incredibly important I mean it
already is and it's it's you know it's a
very different coming from different
starting points and a different history
and then say you know America or the
West is and even that you know it's not
like they don't share a common world but
there's there's different fundamental
perspectives that are that are going on
so it's kind of a good thing for him to
be doing that alright Ben writes I'm
reading mythos if assess finding it
slightly hard to read any advice on
wrapping your head around it read and
reread and reread it is it is a
difficult text
cow Moos philosophy which includes that
and the rebel and you know his other
things like letters to a German friend
often quite difficult often a lot of Lou
two different authors that you need to
track down and figure out he's also
writing in a you know kind of convoluted
style so just keep it at it don't expect
like it with any philosophical text
don't expect to understand everything
right away the way you might with other
disciplines you know but keep at it and
then after you've read the mythos if
assist you definitely want to go on and
read the rebel because he's taking up
some of the same themes and it shows how
Camus has transitioned you know in the
in the Mississippi says it's the you
know the philosophical question is the
question of suicide and the rebel it's a
question of murder and he says something
has happened in the time that I wrote
this book to this book that has changed
not just my perspective but the world
situation that we're in so alright TK
very curious about my existential and
stoic take on resentment well if it it
depends on what you mean by resentment
if you mean something just like anger or
bitterness or something like that
generally you know I'm I'm I work a lot
on the Stoics and the Stoics think that
anger is always something bad I don't
follow them all the way I'm a bit more
Aristotelian in that respect there I
also part with Cicero who thinks the
Aristotelian czar dead wrong on that the
Starks have got it right but resentment
I don't think is a good thing now with
with the existentialists we get some
analyses of what nietzsche calls
ressentiment
and you know the the underground man in
Dostoevsky is talking about something
very similar but he's not using quite
the same terminology and there I think
we had something that's you know quite
interesting and you know there's there's
a fuller analysis I would you know it's
interesting I was just reading
Cicero's Tusculum disputations because
I'm you know going back through it
because I need some stuff for a paper
I'm writing on Plato and Aristotle
believe it or not and Cicero points out
this interesting fact about diseases of
the
he says the aristotelian x' they you
know took the the conversation this way
and did this much and that's good but
the Stoics really did much more in this
respect so Arista Chileans are providing
some of the framework Stoics are
providing some of the you know the nuts
and bolts of it and I think when it
comes to resentment
maybe the existentialists are adding
something new to the picture that the
Stoics the classic Stoics hadn't quite
worked out or you know maybe there's
something new about modern culture that
that that brings that about right
so yeah defaut why was fun on saying
that d colonialization must necessarily
be a violent process well because the
decolonial eyes errs for one thing or
the colonizer spend a lot usually
amenable to doing that he's not unique
in saying things like that right it's
kind of a common viewpoint and and
you're you're only going to make it so
far with with nonviolent resistance so
yeah it's probably enough Stanislav
could you please explain the effect of
michelle the Montaigne's thought on
death and later thinkers such as
Heidegger I don't know that Heidegger I
don't know that Heidegger is referring
to Montana is he if that's the case I
don't really know I mean there's plenty
of people you know meditating on death
so if that's if that's the case then
then you know that would be quite
interesting let's see what else do we
get canal the French guy wrote my PhD
about would he be an existentialist what
do I think about people claiming Hegel's
with proto existentialist so let's take
the second one first
yeah Hegel in certain respects can be
understood as a proto existentialist you
know the in the analyses in for example
the phenomena
ology before you get to the absolute
knowing there's a lot of places where
people are like seeking out the meaning
of their life with Hegel though there's
always like this movement you sorry
there's one thing you know that the
practical the lived the experience was
very important for Hegel but it's always
moving towards the universal right so
you know the other thing too is I think
a lot a lot of people because of Sartre
and de Beauvoir and that's mediated
through tkachev made a lot of Hegel's
master-slave dialectic the master-slave
dialectic is just a sliver in the
phenomenology and it doesn't represent
like the total condition of humankind
not even Marx thought that you know but
a lot of people like to like that
because it's nice and easy to interpret
it's kind of sexy master-slave but it's
it's you know once you've gone through
it a number of times it's actually one
of the lesser less interesting parts of
the phenomenology quite frankly but I
think a lot of people view that as like
so Hegel is contributing something to
the existentialist spectrum because
they're thinking about people later on
like like you know Sartre and like do
boudoirs discussion of the category the
other in introduction of the second sex
right so the guy to take the first
question the guy who I wrote my PhD
about Maurice blown-down he is you know
his first writings are in the 1890s and
he's from a generation before the the
the big French existentialist like
Sartre and Marcel he actually was you
know friends with Marcel he wrote about
Sartre
he what he's doing with his his
essentially phenomenology but it but you
calls with the method of imminence at
first is he an existentialist sort of
he's dealing with the same themes that
many of the existentialist are doing but
but often in much more systematic ways
and in ways that are oriented towards
what's going on
and modern thought on the one side
secular modern thought and I'm Catholic
thought on the other side some people
want to call him an existentialist
there's actually a book out there by I
think it's andreas or Metis that that
reinterprets blown down in terms of
existentialism I read it back when I was
working on my dissertation and that's a
very long time ago so I remember like
saying yeah okay this is this is good
but let's let's read blown-down in his
own right I suppose if I was going to
include him in a class I would what
would I actually use maybe some some
selections from you know lack Co 1993
and I don't know there's stuff to think
about what to assign blown Dells kind of
a murky messy thinker here's an
interesting question Robert Sims what's
the last great movie you've seen great
movies that I've seen that I was like
really impressed by you know I saw the
new Blade Runner movie and I is it Blade
Runner 2040 or 2013 I remember the
actual date on it and we saw it in the
theater and and that movie really is
meant to be seen in the theater in part
because of the soundtrack because you
want something that's got that that's
really heavy bass because they make use
of that a lot but also you want to have
a big screen I think too that was good I
like I like that playing around with the
themes I you know we've really been
watching much fewer movies and more more
TV shows on streaming in the last year I
would say my wife and I I'm kind of
looking forward to having the time to
get to see movies TV shows are a little
bit more manageable so alright I'm not
sure what Pascal's question is about is
it's
to the seventh house and astrology no
idea right right away Suzie I never hear
you say stupid things it's quite
remarkable genuinely well I know I've
said a lot of stupid things maybe I'd
only do it when the cameras off but I
think if I were to go through might
might you know my videos and online
stuff if I actually had the time to do
that I probably could find some stupid
things in there here or there so alright
pension sure can you shortly explain
camos ethics of quantity so briefly
explain it right so this is something he
talks about of the myth of synthesis and
he he says that you know even in an
absurd world you can still have some
sort of ethics and you decide it for
yourself and you can think about it the
the the idea of the quantity thing is
that you you have a certain amount of
time perhaps or vitality or
opportunities so you should try to
maximize them in a way that actually
makes sense for you and that might
change over time so even though the
world may be is absurd and I mean come
who doesn't say the world is absurd by
the way absurdity as he says is divorced
between the human being and the world
and it has to do the the you know the
absurdity is this third term we can
still like you know he takes Don Juan as
an example Don Juan can go and try to
have as much pleasure in in the mode of
having sex and seducing as possible and
that that can be what he structures his
life around we can look at that from the
outside and say oh that's disgusting or
oh that's that's you know stupid this is
do this is doing something better or oh
that's just kind of you know tracking up
meaningless notches on your belt but for
him that can that can be you know the
quantity that he he desires other people
might do it in other ways you know
racking up the
number of mountains they climb right or
you know races that they are on I mean I
I'll probably alienate a few people in
saying this but I just don't understand
people who do like marathons and runs
and bikes and stuff like that they're
like yeah this is my eighth one and I
did this many miles you know my attitude
is always like who cares holy crap but
you know then again I you know shoot
videos on people who have long been dead
and I think that that's quite valuable
as well so I mean from from a cow Moos
Ian's perspective maybe that's kind of a
quantity as well all right
Haven Stricker writes any ideas on
writing a philosophical paper that's
trying to coalesce an eclectic variety
of philosophy and one overarching idea
that's asking a lot I mean trying to do
that in a paper is tough trying to do
that in a book it is tough as well so I
don't know I would I would say what you
want to do is be really clear about what
you're taking from which person or a
tradition and clarify for yourself
you know why you're adopting that and
how it fits into your overall coherent
synthesis you know otherwise I mean you
don't want it to just be a sort of
smorgasbord you know pick a little bit
of salami here a little bit of cheese a
little bit of celery you want it to
actually like fit together in one if not
sink one single dish one one coherent
meal all right if we're using that
metaphor and you know I would I would
make sure that you are attentive to
where when you're combining different
viewpoints that are in some respect and
compatible with each other that you
signal that in some way you don't want
to be doing this kind of new agey I mean
it's not actually New Age it goes back a
long way it's we're all on the same page
man you know this guy's saying the same
thing is this guy saying the same thing
is this
just different language because a lot of
times they're not you know a lot of
times even if they use the same words
they may not mean the same thing by it
you know so I would I would I would pay
attention to them alright DJ see psy
firts maybe
are there any philosophers who have
plunged into her integrated into their
writings the Hebrew wisdom Tech of Kola
Ecclesiastes um yeah I mean chef stuff
talks about it I think if I remember
right I mean not not a lot comes to mind
I mean you're probably thinking about
the vanity of vanities it's all vanities
sort of thing a lot of people read the
early part of that then they don't get
to like the later part where it's like
well yeah I mean it's all kind of
screwed up but here's here's how you
should live anyway you know kind of a
really a fetus approach I don't know
it's not it's not something that I see
coming up an awful lot yeah and it could
be you know I don't haven't read my mana
teas for quite a while so I'm not a good
person to ask about Maimonides but maybe
he discussed it written WAPA what are
your thoughts on psychedelics perception
of these substances seems to change with
the passage of time I've never been a
fan of psychedelics because I've never
been a fan of the people that are into
them I you know this this will strike
many of you is irrational I'm sure but
I'm a big judge of things or books or
movements by the people who are really
into them and if I find that those
people are kind of drips or you know
superficial or saying things that I I
don't you know particularly care for
then I usually I'm like well I'm not
wasting my time on this and and that
that has really been my experience with
a lot of the people who talk about
psychedelics you know going all the way
back to high school people dropping acid
or you know having mushrooms and being
like you know the proverbial
I can taste colors why the hell would I
want to do that you know or have
hallucinations and then there you know
there were people in grad school that
were into that and into other things and
like oh it opens the doors of perception
well I think you could probably open
your doors in other ways right and and
maybe you don't you know you know you're
not dependent so much on a drug in that
case you know and I realize that that
within certain cultural contexts where
there's like a rich fabric that a person
is using things like that in or set of
rituals there's there's more meaning
that could be conveyed but that ain't
the way that most people these days are
using that stuff you know or
experimenting with it so I leave that
that sort of experimentation to other
people and I take the stuff that they
say with a grain of salt I'm more
especially if they circulate now it's
inevitable man you know it's a mystical
experience and that sort of stuff I'm
not really interested in if it's not
communicable and I can't you know wrap
my head around it without having to jump
into it I've already got enough stuff
that I got a handle that way like like
love and Parenthood and death and things
like that you know I want I want you
know if somebody's gonna use stuff like
that I want a report that will you know
make sense to me so all right let's see
Wesley Burton what do you think it's
arts attempt to synthesize
existentialism and Marxism well I think
that I mean he was sort of bound to try
to do that in part because you know if
you think about where Marxism comes from
it's not like somebody you know at one
point in time was like man we need to do
something just to screw things up and
and you know you know throw a wrench in
the gear of capitalism that's otherwise
working really well it came out of a
genuine you know movement and there are
many other people in this this movement
broader you know socialism anarchism you
know critique of capitalism movement
they were like holy crap this is doing
some real damage to people and you know
we define days to to make more humane or
to to burn the clock or to you know move
forward into something different
and some of the things that Marks has to
say are still quite valuable today some
of it is sort of like you know like with
Freud like if you're if you're into
Freud and you still think the Oedipus
complex is some sort of universal thing
okay you might you might made that into
a fetish right and there's some things I
think in Marx's works that are like that
too but it makes sense that that it's a
thoughtful person at the time would be
engaging Marx many other people are some
are you know some are coming to the
conclusion that no no this is not going
to work this is something that that
ended up you know splitting not just
Sartre and Camus but sart's and other
people including Marilyn Ponte apart
from from him and de Beauvoir Sartre was
was was you know he was willing to
acknowledge that the Marxist regimes
that that he was seeing were not really
you know living up to what what you know
what Marxism was supposed to be about
but he was still holding on to it as
kind of an ideology and you know it
makes sense how you would combine the
two of those in a broad sense but you
still have to be critical of you know
things that are that are you know like
the Soviet system for example all right
let's see what else we got here Oh
Robert asks this is a more personal
question than a general one but how do
you determine one interpretation of a
text is better than another
interpretation I think you look at you
know whether the interpretation of the
text is well informed
you know if it's saying things about the
text that seem clearly at odds with the
text you know then you got to say okay
what's going on here is the the writer
who's the interpreter proposing like a
deeper meaning to the text then what I'm
normally seeing or is there something
else going on here that I need to be
attuned to alright so I want to see it
being well informed I don't I prefer to
see people who actually spend a lot of
time with an author rather than just
jumping in and coming up with a
revolutionary new you know idea
I want to see that it takes in the
totality of the author's thought and
work as much as possible I'm looking for
you know what it contributes what it's
bringing to bear it's one of those
things that's hard to provide criteria
for the longer you spend with an author
the more you can kind of smell the the
people who are full of full of crap and
you know also tell the ones who are like
it's almost so there's an olfactory
image then there's the ones where you're
you're listening trim something rings
true right and you're like yeah okay
yeah that is what it is what's going on
with Aristotle haven't thought about
that that's that's quite good you know
so I'd say that's that's part of it but
again I don't spend a lot of time a
secondary let you know in part because
I'm so busy reading primary lit and
rereading it and developing resources
and teaching classes and meeting with
clients and stuff like that so all right
meets miss Tian says I'm reading chef's
stuffs Athens and Jerusalem and I like
it very much what do you think of the
book I like it you know that's just off
intervention in the 1930s Christian
philosophy debates by the way those
pieces that you're seeing there the
chapters of it were originally published
as separate pieces in the review they
made a physique anymore all around 3435
they think may be going on in 236 it's
good book you know it's just office is a
great thinker hard to pin down but but
well worth reading I think so all right
let's see here a lot of questions
am i is from ma Jackie are you familiar
with Stuart Kyle Minnie's a biologist
and works with origins of life and
crystallisation order nature which are
metaphysically interesting concepts no
I'm not familiar with it at all
well there's many people I'm not
familiar with so probably more than I am
familiar with me Smith's 10 points out
that jacket lil has written a book on
Ecclesiastes reason for being is the
name of the book but there you go
somebody who I haven't read for a very
long time as well all right let's see
here Forrest rebel says I often start my
students with existentialist literature
and film in addition to just a few of
only the most basic essays covering the
principal themes freedom responsibility
anxiety despair etc yeah that's that's
one way people can can do it I'm a bit
more I'd say old school I like them to
be reading the texts and then the you
know films and stuff like that could be
supplementary because otherwise I tend
to find that the students will often
ignore the the texts then stick with the
the film's especially in these again in
these six-week class is not a hell of a
lot of time for that sort of thing let's
see Oswald Spengler dr. sailor approved
he is into the CIA MKULTRA shell I guess
I don't know
hungry American just picked up Kaufman's
book about Nietzsche again and if I'm
great enjoyment out of reading it as
influential as a book as it is do you
think it's an accurate portrayal of the
philosopher I don't think there is any
like super accurate portrayal of the
philosopher Nietzsche there's like more
accurate and less accurate in part
because Nietzsche is a non systematic
deliberately self-contradicting figure I
wouldn't necessarily even buy
Nietzsche's own takes on meetcha you
know for example when he talks about the
birth
tragedy and all of its flaws I don't I
don't actually buy into all of what he's
saying with that and you know I wouldn't
necessarily buy his own stuff Kaufman is
certainly a sort of standard interpreter
you could say of Nietzsche been a long
time since I've read his his stuff you
know again not a great person to ask
about secondary lip you know I'm more
interested usually in reading but you
know like if I want to read somebody
else's take on Nietzsche I might read
you know say chest off it was his book
on you know Nietzsche and Dostoevsky
right solemnly also has a book on me it
shows quite interesting all right uh
let's see here
Ben yeah could do it to a slightly
off-topic are you really gonna review
the Game of Thrones finale that would be
fun
I might review it I mean I'm not sure
what format I would I would do it in and
I have been reading some of the
interesting like pieces in different
opinion journals about like what went
wrong with it and you know what what you
know might my take on the Game of
Thrones thing is that Martin wrote some
really great books they're not perfect
of course and there's things that that
people might complain about but the
books you know one through five they're
their quality stuff that makes sense you
know there's sort of the swan song for a
great authors whose work straddles
different fields of speculative fiction
he writes equally well in horror fantasy
science fiction or mixes of all three
Game of Thrones there's a lot of moving
parts going on there it's sort of like
imagine dune you know only with way more
fashions and personalities and set you
know not in space but on one single
place and there's a great scope to it
and the writers HBO saw you know oh
there's a big fan base for this
we can probably you know do some really
lush arrangements and bring in some
talent that we can get you know fairly
cheaply because there's plenty of actors
and you know this will kind of make
their there you know profiles and all
that and then they brought in writers
and writers for TV don't usually know
how to write well in terms of grand
stories you see this all the time with
like sci-fi shows like think about
Battlestar Galactica great show great
you know conception of like how the
Vipers would fight and interesting
things about the Cylons but you know the
last three less and say two three
seasons really weak crap in part cuz the
writers don't know how to write to a
successful ending same thing happened to
Stargate you know bigger and bigger and
bigger enemies to fight and eventually
just kind of fizzles out right now when
it comes to these two writers and
directors you know they didn't know how
to handle the the story itself which is
perfectly understandable because it's a
huge story and you got to be somewhat
attuned to like the ethnos involved of
something like that and I think that
they were better for you know like
writing stuff for typical Hollywood
stories you know and once they started
going off-book
their writing got worse and worse and
worse they were relying on Martyn's
storytelling abilities and thought as
their crutch and turns out that they
didn't really have the chops to see it
through and they saw through it and in
terms of what they know how to do but
it's sort of like imagine like I don't
know
you know I'll use some heavy metal
examples so you know I do we just saw a
Judas Priest and Uriah Heep recently
here right Judas Priest
great band you know 75 onward major
contributions to metal stuff
they've they've got this ethos that
they've built up over time they've got
this fan base that will turn out for
them they didn't even need to introduce
any of the songs this time because
everyone like knew what was coming up
and recognized that even the new songs
off of firepower right there were very
few song introductions so they've got a
sort of narrative universe composed of
their songs now imagine some record
producers like we're gonna we're gonna
like really make the band better we've
got to fine-tune some stuff these two
guitar guys I understand that they were
replacements for the original guitarist
what if I'm just kind of spitballing
here what if we got rid of one of them
and instead we brought in a guy with one
of those like synthesizer guitars right
you know what the keyboards wouldn't
that be kind of cool I think that kids
are into that you know and and you'd be
like what the hell are you talking about
you know and I've seen a lot of bands
these days like I'm Saturday Night Live
where they have like two drummers what
if we had two drummers you know oh maybe
one guy is on bongos what the hell are
you talking about so that's that's
essentially you know these these people
who want to make adjustments and fix the
narrative and all that they they know
what they're doing in terms of some some
other thing that they're used to doing
but they were totally out of their depth
and it came to Martin so you know there
that's my take on it I don't know what I
would what kind of video I should shoot
about it or I don't maybe I should do a
chat about it I don't know I I have to
give this a bit more thought so
all right mr. Joe a sir can you comment
on any parallels between chests often to
lose especially related to their views
on truth in their attack and can
constrain prefab structures and so and
so forth well there you've got it that's
what they have in common
chef stuff too isn't a big believer in
rhizomes I don't know if they lose
references chef Stauffer died I'd have
to go back and look in some of his stuff
I'd be kind of surprised if he hadn't
run across him at any point but I think
they're doing different kinds of
you know it's important to remember that
chef stuff is a theist he's a he's a guy
who's trying to figure out where God
fits into this like screwed up
world that we've got and not not as a
sort of like highest-value or any sort
of other thing like that but he's trying
to take on the insights of you know deep
thinkers like like Dostoevsky and
Nietzsche and he you know he talks about
others as well before he discovers
Kierkegaard and yet you know to preserve
preserve some sort of intellectual space
and to be like totally ruthlessly honest
with himself he didn't seem to be so
much interested in in an experiment in
deriving new concepts as say Toulouse
was so I you know they they both could
kind of fit into what Boris grosse is
called anti philosophy way of doing
philosophy that's not that of typical
philosophers but but so could many other
people nikkor my thinking about Marxism
is it's essentially about political
paradigm changes it was never meant to
be taken as a prescription but rather
description I think that's wrong I
wouldn't try to categorize what the
essence of Marxism was people do this
all time I think Marxism names a bunch
of different things all assembled
together under one big category and some
people are doing one one of the things
and some people are doing others and you
know it's it's it's kind of up to them
what they want to pick and choose from
right so yeah all right Forrest rebel
start synthesis of the two meaning
existentialism and Marxism fails because
his notion of radical freedom betrays
Marx eschatological determinism of the
dialectic yeah I mean I thought I'd say
that that's true but maybe you want to
get rid of that aspect of Marxism you
know it depends on who's Marxism you're
working with doesn't it so yeah I know
Johnny says I know this doesn't have to
do with existentialism but I'm currently
reading The Fountainhead I was wondering
what are your
their thoughts on I'm around you know
I've said these quite a few times and
may as well you know spend a little bit
of time talking about this brand is a
philosopher and she deserves to be
counted as a philosopher she's not just
an ideologue or something like that that
said she's not a very good philosopher
and she's actually not not that great of
a narrative writer either characters
were kind of wooden and stilted so if
you know she's she's somebody who's
interesting to study I teach her in my
classes in part because there's so many
people influenced by Rand out there
including the bulk of our current
Republican Party so she's you know she's
important for people to know and I teach
her like in an ethics class as a typical
representative of a certain kind of
egoist ethics her history of philosophy
you know her views on the figure she
likes like Aristotle the figure she
dislikes like Plato or Nietzsche she
doesn't know what the hell she's talking
about
she clearly you know either didn't read
them very carefully or had a beef with
them and thought it was it was cool to
be unfair to them or you know was so
blinded by her own ideology and her own
reaction against you know the Russian
Revolution and collectivism that that
she just can't give you an accurate take
on on other philosophical thinkers but
you know there's interesting ideas in
there oftentimes there's places where
you're like you're reading here and
you're like okay this is this is
actually quite quite good generally
anything like that in her works you can
find in somebody else without all the
other ideological commitments and
vitriol right so I think it's here's the
last thing I'll say I think it's it's um
it's a shame that the people who have
the most to say about Rand are either on
one extreme or the other they're either
these people who really you know drank
the proverbial kool-aid and they're like
I'm Rand is the best ever she knows
everything or they're on the other
extreme and they're like she's the demon
she's terrible you know
don't ever mention her name or maybe
she'll show up right and then you know
there's nothing really in the middle
between them and they
lay off of each other because they're
both I mean the way that people who are
kind of ideologue as well right
you know the people over here could say
see how misunderstood she is you know
she's she's being suppressed and then
they get to feel like they're kind of in
the know about things and the people
over here look at the the knuckleheads
over here and they're like see what her
followers are like you know she's an
evil poison so it's unfortunate there is
some good good you know literature out
there you know discussing brand that
isn't is literal place in Catholicism
well first of all there's no such thing
as Catholicism okay anything that any
time people name that they're naming a
boogeyman or some construct of their own
imagination there's you know this
incredibly complex Christian religion
with many different interpretations one
of the biggest of which is coming from
you know the Catholic Church which is on
the same page for the most part with
many of the older Protestant churches
there we go on the same page with many
of the Protestant churches and also with
the Orthodox and all that and you know
so there's no ISM there's no one single
thing that's being being discussed right
I'm not sure why we're not getting good
check the mic all right there we go
that's better yeah so so you know there
is no no ISM out they are corresponding
to two terming Catholicism do Christians
think that hell is a literal place
depends on what you mean by literal
place I mean do you mean
like space like this like it's a room or
something
I don't think too many Christian
thinkers from very very early on ever
considered it to be a literal place like
you know a space like this there were
some people who you know when they had
the idea of the earth is being a globe
and you know heavens are up there and
hell is down below we're thinking in
terms of the infernal regions but that's
kind of a difficult cosmology to make
work right so all right
oops so let's see the scroll up here
there's a lot of questions here all
right so
do I have any thoughts on Berjaya I came
across him in the library writing my
term paper for existentialism found him
so interesting i scrapped my paper wrote
my paper on those from dan the man yeah
I think he's somebody interesting to
check out he's not somebody who has
spent much time with in the last like 10
years so I'm pretty hazy on a lot of the
stuff that he had to say he was part of
that circle by the way that did spend
time like you know at the Marcel's house
a lot of these you know we often don't
understand this but how small the the
milieu of Parisian intellectuals was he
might say Parisian by jiraiya f-- was
Russian yeah well that's where all those
Emma Christ went after the Revolution
they hung out in Paris so he's you know
I think he's worth reading but again I
don't have enough to say about him that
that would really help all right
Wensley Burton I agree I think too many
people left us today uphold Marx as a
prophet Marxism as an analytical
framework for critique of political
economy so whatever anybody wants to
make of it you know I don't know that
many leftist I know quite a few of them
who view Marx as a prophet I think
that's kind of a you know maybe you're
hanging on the wrong leftist areas or
something all right let's see what else
we got here Jimmy from the golden
notebook speaking of textual
interpretation will you discuss Bart's
the death of the author and fuko's what
is an author in the future how are you
distinguish their ideas well I'll do
separate things
their ideas will be distinguished that
way all right I don't know if I'm going
to do anything on fucose what is an
author fucose anything anytime soon
urbarts the death of the author I'm you
know more likely if we're going to do
continental figures I'm doing people
that I have to teach in my class
so unless people commission and anybody
who wants to Commission me to shoot
videos on particular text they can
certainly write me for a ratio but I
have so much backlog stuff I got to do
for the classes that I'm teaching and I
don't end up teaching that sort of stuff
in my class is very often maybe down the
line I could you know but it depends on
depends on the schools commissioning me
to do that all right
Robert Sims the problem with Kaufman was
he was too household Heidegger's weird
reading at nature and his two volumes do
loses another one a read nature in a new
way I brought up the interpretation yeah
I mean there's like literally thousands
of people who interpreted nature I like
you know de losses interpretation is
pretty interesting you're right about
that
I remember presenting that in graduate
school so oh there's a good question
bathtub gin 1 4 1 2 is it possible to
marry the metaphysics of Heidegger at
Thomas Aquinas depends on what you mean
by Mary people have tried doing that
sort of thing because there's nothing
that there's no two like dolls that
people won't like try to swish together
and make into one right that's that's a
lot of dissertations and first books and
projects and papers come up but the
question is is the hybrid actually
viable and you know frankly I don't
think so
I don't even know why you would want to
I mean why would you want to try to
marry them why not just settle for
pointing out where they might work
together well and where they where they
don't fit together well you know I'm
just adjusting the latex it's getting
kind of dark in here there we go that's
a little better but you know if you want
to try to do that go on ahead I mean I
for me it would be more like let's take
a look at what Heidegger is to say about
truth and what Aquinas has to say about
truth which by the way requires that you
know what what Aristotle said and what
Anselm said
what this person said and we'll see
whether we can like cobble together
something that provides insights but I
why would you want us like put the two
of them together as some sort of hole
Oswald Spengler are you favorable
towards Collin Wilson's near
existentialism never read Wilson so I
don't I don't actually know this me Stan
what do you think of shale errs book on
resentiment seems like a true gem and
especially relevant to our times I think
it's a great book I think that's a
Schaller was another interpreter of
Nietzsche who is well worth reading I
think that he's you know he's on to the
right things I don't I don't entirely by
you know Schaller also still tends to be
a little bit schematic in some respects
from time to time but you know he's I
think what he's doing is pretty good
all right let's see here
program what is the connection between
handle and existential ISM a lot
existentialist frame what they're doing
in opposition to Hegel because Hegel is
sort of the you know representative at
the time of really systematic philosophy
some of them take on some stuff from
Hegel you know particularly they like
the master-slave dialectic Kierkegaard
is of course reacting against Hegel but
also using dialectical terminology so
I'd say that that's pretty much yet oh
here we go
words words everywhere how important do
you think reading literature is for to
an understanding of existentialism and
there he means or she means Camus Sartre
boudoir more modern writers rather than
reading hard philosophy well if you're
reading as essentialism yeah you you do
want to read the literature some of the
people that we count as existentialist
are not philosophers literary figures
like rainer maria rilke or fruit nor
Franz Kafka right
others like the ones we were mentioning
write short stories or plays copy of
ourselves another great example
Gabriela Marcel also by the way wrote
music and he had this beautiful
statement in his conversations with paul
ricoeur where he said that my philosophy
is sort of like the peninsula stretching
out the plays are like islands but
what's connecting all them together is
music which is kind of a cool thing to
say isn't an interesting idea so if you
won't understand existentialism you need
to read literature Dostoevsky another
great example right he didn't write any
philosophy his characters talk
philosophy but he doesn't write
philosophy the people who are writing in
response to them are very attuned to
literature to music to the Fine Arts
you know Rilke was Rodin secretary for a
number of years so I don't think you can
actually learn or teach existentialism
without engaging a lot of literature
alright good what did you write my
dissertation on I wrote it on this guy
Maurice Blondell and some of the themes
in his as still yet untranslated works
particularly his later metaphysical
trilogy of being action and thought and
I focused on what was called the
concrete logic an idea that he began
working with in his early stuff and what
he called the option the need to stake
out a position that that fundamentally
committed oneself one way or another and
boy was it a mess but you know I didn't
have very much guidance all right let's
see
for travel Italy kinder situatedness the
fact that our being is always historical
contextual Solomon has a book on it okay
what else let's talk about you jack here
nikkor my biggest problem with Game of
Thrones is that people watch it and come
away thinking about the Middle Ages is
like Game of Thrones when if anything it
was the opposite
well the Middle Ages Muslim like
anything it was just talking with a
client about this there is no there's no
thing called the Middle Ages there is
all these different cultures and
developments going on at different times
and they permeate each other and you
know so it's very difficult to
generalize but you can't even say well
feudalism well yes and no and depending
on how you look at it you know what era
or you're talking about it's you know I
don't know people who watch Game of
Thrones and then take that as their view
of the Middle Ages if you say that there
are I guess I have to trust you yeah I
think a lot of people are already
interested in medieval things and then
you know get into something like Game of
Thrones so all right gam brick does
anyone think people focus too much on
secondary live I've noticed some
professors and grad students
recommending going to secondary lit when
struggling with the primary text this
seems bad nothing bad about it they're
you know it's just remember secondary
lit is not the actual text you're you
know sometimes it's like finding a
really good teacher or guide I mean when
you're taking a class and the
professor's up there lecturing that's a
secondary taxes right they're not just
presenting you know whoever it is that
they're talking about but sooner or
later you want to have your own
authentic sustained engagement with the
the primary text you know you don't want
to just hear somebody else's to take on
descartes right and you want to read
Descartes and see what's there
I think that's that's important and and
yeah there there are some places where
people focus
way too much on secondary literature
especially when the secondary literature
forms like a nice tight community of the
people who they like to read and talk
about but it's often you know secondary
literature can often be a little
incestuous right everybody reads these
these particular people and their
students and then you know that becomes
the commentary was really cool so if you
can read like different languages like
go to the research library and just like
go down the halls and say pick somebody
like Aristotle right so you know you're
gonna find some good English language
history of philosophy stuff that's
really well-informed about the text then
you find a lot of crap kind of you know
analytic constructions of Aristotle and
you'll be like yeah this is kind of you
know I see what they're doing here but
but it's not really that connected to
Aristotle's text let's start reading
what they're doing in like French
literature German literature Italian
literature on Aristotle and it opens up
a whole different world right the
secondary lid he doesn't even have the
same rules and how they write the
secondary so you know that that can be
worth checking out
all right canal have my read teaching
Hegel by Robert Solomon no I am NOT I
mean if I'm gonna read secondary Lit
stuff it's probably not going to be a
teaching so and so it's probably going
to be something else Robert Sims I'd say
there's a lot of great literature out
there that explores the human condition
with a lot of depth that can match the
tomes under the existentialist umbrella
yeah that's true the existentialist
don't have the market cornered on that
point true Paschal asks where Paco asks
who's your favorite band in song I don't
have one in either because there's too
many bands that would be hedging their
way into that I would say you know the
bands that I tend to like the malls most
of them are metal bands classic metal
bands
a few exceptions of be like say new
model army who else it's hard to think
of who would also fit in there but you
know I'm really big a classic battle so
you know do
Iron Maiden Judas Priest I Motorhead
Raven except scorpions you know Black
Sabbath some of the most of the stuff
you know
deep purple uriah heep bands like that
that's the kind of stuff I'm really into
alright DFAC what is your favorite work
of ancient Epicureans well it's kind of
hard to say cuz we don't have most of
what they wrote right we don't have a
hell of a lot of stuff we've got a
little bit of stuff from Epicurious
we've got the creatures is the order of
things and we've got some filler damos
that's that's pretty much it so what
would I say I guess I would hold on from
critius just because we've got the most
material there to work with Jimmy from
the golden notebook how will i comment
on the eventful GJ peterson debate i'd
say it's not really an event at all
other people can comment on it i don't
care
so alright Ben again I'm 13 how did you
reconcile stoicism and your Catholicism
or am I seeing a conflict where there's
none so maybe this is in the part where
the sound was out there's no such thing
as Catholicism you know there's no like
one systematic body of doctrine or
something like that
there's the Christian religion and
that's incredibly advanced you start
including all the different you know
people influenced by it writing on it
you know because it's not just like say
the Bible or the Christian community
it's also all these great thinkers early
on like you know just murdered locked on
theism John Cassian all these people
living this this stuff out and you
notice that a lot of them actually
by the way wrote about the Stoics like
clement of alexandria did you know or
Justin Martyr you know and quite a few
stoic things got their way in well you
know there's places where like I don't
maybe say believe in the universal
conflagration but they're even stoic so
said yeah that's kind of kinda hazy
right I'm an eclectic I I take a bunch
of different thing Mazal ask me how can
you buy into stoicism and
aristotelianism at the same time because
like Cicero I take what I think works
from from the different things
and what's more true and I try to you
know harmonize them as best as I can and
where there's areas where there's a
clear conflict I say well I don't buy
this and I buy this or maybe I don't buy
both of them you know that that's how
you do that sort of thing
alright a lot of back and forth about
Rand there Wesley Burton she's just
strainer for dummies strugglers a lot
better the grand and I don't and sterner
and Rand are not compatible by the way I
think if you actually like look at them
carefully they're not going to fit to it
- well let's see or Iran stuff alright
the forest rebels Jack Martin is a
Catholic existentialist through those we
asked about the two maybe eight angels
so some of the personal ascent elements
of it to Schaller for sure Bernie air
Mooney air smelled a little bit
different than that yeah mark
Jacque Martin got into it for a while he
wrote a book about it
I don't know that he ever really was
that existentialist but you know he can
get called that if you want a Catholic
existentialist Gabriele Marcel right
he's the first person to use the word
existentialism an existentialist in
French he said he liked my Ratan and
like
that blonde elf and a few others were
also converts there's other thinkers who
are Christian existentialist in France
at the time as well and trying to recall
some of them maybe I'll remember later
on all right dude let's go down back and
forth here math Wolfe who says yo I say
yo back to him run away Suze I prefer to
think of Hell as being outside of God's
love which we would substitute you could
substitute for heretical needs and
desires being satisfied or not yeah it's
a pretty typical you know classic
Christian way of thinking about it right
being stuck with yourself
Nick earth if you put a Quietus and
Heidegger together you get David Bentley
Hart again a sprinkle in some some
orthodoxy there too so you have to pick
some orthodox father to put in there as
well let's see here trying to read this
one um would you say it's better to
learn or read and be more like an open
minded observer in order to develop your
own take on things produce text if you
had to choose at first it's definitely
better to be an open minded observer
because there's all these people are
like I want to do my own philosophy and
you're like what have you read nothing I
don't want to like you know spoil
anything but you know introducing other
people's ideas really well you're gonna
do a lot of reinventing the wheel and
let me know how that goes for you they
come back and they've got this thing and
they're like you know here's my system
you're like this looks like watered-down
Spinoza who's but also you know like man
you should have read that stuff so it's
important if you do want to do something
on your own that you spend some time
with you know other people's stuff the
same thing goes for if you want to write
let it
I mean don't just write what you know or
something like that read a lot of other
people if it's good you learn some
things from that right and then I think
when you're developing your own take on
things maybe someday you develop you
know some sort of a new original take or
maybe your original take is a new way of
bringing together Aristotle and somebody
else from the present or applying
Schaller to environmental ethics and
that's perfectly fine too so all right
Binh Ngoc says what's your take on cow
Moos idea philosophical suicide so he's
definitely against that he thinks that
it's a bad thing to do and he considers
a lot of different philosophers
particularly theistic philosophers as
engaging in philosophical suicide
because they're if they're sort of like
turning off reason and I would say he's
wrong about that but I think you know
come who was one of these people who
really tried to be as open as possible
to what other thinkers had to put on the
table but he just couldn't he was being
honest he couldn't find himself in
agreement with them and he saw what they
were doing
essentially shutting shutting the mind
off and a wave like not dealing with the
fact that we live within the absurd all
right Peter Vivar how do you feel about
heidegger's black notebooks and the
quote mining done with them to taint his
whole philosophy of sympathetic to nasty
ideology well I think that you know the
it's not anything new I mean we we have
the whole Heidegger thing twenty years
ago before the black notebooks were even
found and a lot of scholars were you
know taking the position he's a Nazi and
everything even being in time is
contaminated and being in time is
problematic and in some respects right
there's there's some things about you
know how
tradition works that you can see where
Nazism what it that more attractive to
Heidegger given the time that he was in
so this is not a new problem
it's just intensified because there were
also people who are like you know you
can like neatly distinguish the Nazi
parts from the non Nazi parts and we're
gonna get we're going to say you're
right about the Nazi parts but
everything else is a-okay and then there
was the rest of us who were like you
know I just want to retain her and I
don't to buy into everything that he
says and you know the things that I
think are problematic I'll deal with
them an ad hoc basis so you know it's
it's silly to say that his whole
philosophy is tainted because we
discovered the black notebooks it you
know just as silly as it was when we
knew that he was a Nazi before but you
know you do have to actually face up to
it you can't just say well every idea
that he had is you know just part of
this this innocent philosophical system
right all right Pavel Ivanovich hi
doctor sailor I've been reading the
phenomenology of spirit wonder if I
should read some of other Hegel's works
essays side by side also after the
phenomenology of spirit should I go into
the greater or lesser logic if you mean
by that the encyclopedia logic or the
science of logic science the logic
follows right after the phenomenology so
that would be the one you'd want right
encyclopedia logic is a lot easier meat
should you read other of Hegel's works
or essays side by side I mean side by
side just read the phenomenology by
itself that's already a head cracker
then maybe read something else after
that or before that it's not like
there's there's some sort of generic
progression or connection between the
two I'll tell you this his lectures are
a hell of a lot easier to read the
phenomenology of spirit and you might
get more out of reading those and by the
way you don't have to feel like it to
plow through the entire phenomenology
the spirit all the way
the very added you know and then only
after that like start rereading it when
you read the phenomenology of spirit you
got to go over the sections over and
over and over again just to figure out
what the hell he's saying on at the time
all right
it hurts to live garden talking about
literature do you think surrealist ideas
of any place in modern philosophy I'm
not sure what you mean by have a place
like do they have a legitimate place
like philosophers should be considering
them I mean anything's fair game really
modern philosophy you know if we're not
using that the technical term where it's
something that ended basically around
you know 1850 or so or maybe 1800 with
19th century philosopher do you mean
like the philosophy of the present day
yeah you can you can you know read
surrealist the thing to remember is you
always if you're doing philosophy you
have to be able to make a case for why
the thing that you're doing the thing
you're really interested in shouldn't
matter to anybody else so you got to be
able to communicate about it to others
and if so if you're if you're really
into whatever you know sort of realist
author or painter or filmmaker or
whatever you've got to explain to other
people why there's some philosophical
import there and if you can do that then
then sure bring it in all you want let's
see here to do all right miss
Jew joy sir thanks so much for the
resources you provide Christian
existential ISM Jewish existentialism do
any other religions engage with
existential ISM what do I think of all
the theme of theological existentialism
well I would say first off you know I've
said this before I'm I'm very interested
in religious figures where religion
doesn't wind up being a problem solver
for them and smoothing everything out
and answering all the questions but
where it makes their lives and their
thought more complicated Kierkegaard is
definitely somebody like that chest off
is definitely somebody like that you
know I I don't know if we I think we can
say Tillich and is I mean Berjaya I've
definitely as Dostoevsky is so those
those those are the thinkers that I
think are important and every of our
salt every time that they're considering
their religion they don't like you know
they just just throw a Bible verse at
you or something say well okay salt they
use it for profound meditations on human
existence and justice and injustice
what's demanded of us and it's the same
thing if you think about you know to try
to live up to the Torah and follow the
commandments very difficult to try to
live according to the Sermon on the
Mount that that'll like transform your
life and it won't transform your life
into somebody protesting outside of an
abortion clinic or you know you know
engaging in a lot of political discourse
or something like that or being
condemned natori another's it'll
transform your life and to somebody who
is you know trying to use Paul's term
and character guards term working out
their salvation and pure trembles so do
other religions engage with
existentialism
I mean existentialism was really a
Western movement there were some some
Buddhist monks who who came to Heidegger
and had a conversation with him
and we're staying at what they were what
they were teaching was similar to what
he was doing but I don't know if you
want to call that existentialism so all
right I could any books you would like
to see a movie or TV series adaptation
of well that's a great question
and we have to include not just an
invitation but a really good faithful
adaptation all right no Hollywood
[ __ ] you know take half the
characters out introduce new arcs but
they actually like sticking to the
historically what would I mean think
about the ones that I've done they don't
talk so I know there's a Lovecraft thing
in the works but I don't know I don't
know too much about where it is right
now and I'd like to see I'm looking
forward to seeing that
you know Mervyn Pyke's Gormenghast was
the trilogy was done by the sci-fi
channel but it's been a long time since
I seen it I think it was decent but that
could definitely is another pass I mean
there's a lot of us located at Green
movies that were just texts that could
be done that would be really great
same thing with philip k dick a lot of
his stuff has been adapted but there's
still plenty of other cool things out
there you know Roger Zelazny Chronicles
of amber would be fun to see Octavia
Butler's series about you know the
aliens saving saving the remnants of
people from a destroyed earth and then
reintroducing that in the genetic
engineering be difficult to pull off to
do good writing for that but but it
would be quite cool if it were done so
others there's some ideas let's see here
Christian Martinez listen to Death Grips
and I don't really listen to much new
metal stuff the stuff that I do is
either doom metal or power metal or you
know new wave of traditional heavy metal
there's so much classic stuff that you
know it's got to be really good for me
to get into nikkor seems to think I'm a
Boomer which is you know maybe maybe
you're a millennial and you think
everybody hold it here's a Boomer I'm a
Generation X person could do I think
that Nietzsche will become more useful
to the less cause in the future probably
not you know you know that's a good
question I think that the the Nietzsche
as providing culture critique stuff that
could be like harnessed by say feminists
I think that's kind of run its course
there's you know me just kind of outside
of the political spectrum when you get
down to it by the way the people on the
right who are attorneys need to usually
they don't know what they're talking
about so alright words words everywhere
I do I have a favorite album from the
classic metal bands that I imagined do I
like any modern metal any death black
progressive metal on my tastes no I
don't have a favorite album because it's
you know there's so many good ones out
there again all I could do is come up
with lists like I said though the modern
stuff that I'd like could be like you
know doom metal and you know some power
metal and you know the stuff it's
modeled after the traditional heavy
metal
I don't like death metal I don't like
black metal I like some progressive
metal but most of that's kind of old
stuff you know much of the genre stuff I
just find too gimmicky it just turns me
on so
all right Diogenes the cynic what do I
make of Hemingway just stop reading A
Farewell to Arms to watch this
how many ways good I enjoyed having
spent a long time sits at brendham he
actually fits into the existentialist
spectrum we often used the if you have a
longer class because the clean
well-lighted place right
to illustrate existentialist themes the
idea of dignity and facing death
I don't know as he could turn out to be
somebody who if I picked him back up
again I wouldn't enjoy it though so
alright getting a getting close to
having to end so I can get out of work
again
see here okay so this is a good one to
go out on from been a yak so I think
that while critiquing true world
theories nature kind of designed his own
true world theory that never matched
nobody really knows what the ubermensch
is meetcha is quite cagey about that and
he doesn't he doesn't use that term in
all in his works right he will talk
about all sorts of other figures that
might be the ubermensch or they might
not be the over match so I don't think
he's giving you like a coherent
systematic picture of that and it makes
sense if the rumor matches anything like
what he's saying where where it's
somebody who is beyond us the question
is how would we recognize them you know
when we see them and and you know I have
never really I don't really buy this
this this idea that the meaning of our
life would be bringing about the
ubermensch I see that as sort of a
despairing attitude on each this part
myself but no it's not a true world
theory it Nietzsche is he's not he's not
generating a new overarching replacement
theory on his own and he's not saying we
have to like totally get rid of all that
stuff by the way and have just like a
pure primal chaos or anything like that
he wants us to have a different more
sophisticated attitude towards theories
one that takes into account what their
their moral basis and import and
direction is how when he calls value
right over and over again so or
valuation right the arts and marathon
and transvaluation you know so I don't
think that the ubermensch people do this
also like each of you that you're all
about perspective ilysm isn't that just
a perspective itself I don't think those
are those critiques
really work well so this is a good place
to leave off
I gotta go shoot more videos Marcel and
Hegel and do some writing and do some
grading and stuff like that so thanks
everybody for for joining me and I hope
to see you again in the ether some other
time and we'll go over this this
everyone will do another thing on
existentialism next month since I'll
still be teaching the class so all right
I'll see everybody have a great
afternoon if you're in this area morning
evening whenever whatever's going on by
you